president Trump met with the president
of South Korea to discuss North Korea
yeah yeah yeah yeah the meeting
consisted of five minutes about nuclear
weapons and 90 minutes of Trump saying
so wait which Korea are you again would
you guys wear t-shirts or something
president Trump has demanded that
Congress investigate the special
prosecutor who was investigating him
yeah yeah Trump's remarks were published
in this morning's issue of things
innocent people say strange yeah I
literally put my tongue in my cheek a
sinkhole has opened up on the White
House lawn true story yeah apparently
another one of milania's tunnels
collapsed inside
Wow I always love them oh goody
yeah just tell number six she has
tunnels that went down everywhere
what's exciting the US Postal Service
announced they will release their first
scratch-and-sniff stamps yeah yeah that
explains why they have canceled their
salute to Kid Rock big kid Rock crowd
huh yeah I gotta tell you it doesn't
smell great probably smells fine yeah
yeah all right thanks for backing me up
Andy
I'm on their side yeah that's smart
there's more of them during a court case
in New Zealand true story a man was
forced to have his penis measured yeah
the man said this is the last time I
fight a parking ticket
does that joke even makes sense all
right okay I enjoyed it I don't know why
a note yeah I don't know why I stopped
to question it
you